I'm Elizabeth moss and this is how I
became Shirley Jackson the script came
to me so it wasn't my idea to do the
film or tell the story and I'm jealous
I wish it was it would have been a great
idea I would have had but it came to me
as a screenplay and it was a brilliant
screenplay it was an adaptation of the
book and I hadn't know anything about
Shirley Jackson is read the lottery but
I no idea about her personal life
so my first introduction to her was
through that through that script what
happens to all lost girls thank oh so I
started with her stories because and
novels because I felt like that you know
where where do you begin and there so I
started with that and then I continued
to sort of read as we went along the
through the process of making the film
even on set but I started there there's
a lot of by graphical material out there
this great book IRA's Franklin that's a
big biography and there's a lot of you
know you can sift through the internet
and find you know go down some holes and
find a lot there and then I I had access
to a recording of her reading lottery
and that's where being my dialect coach
Cooley developed the accent and her
voice her voice is quite a bit lower
than mine
and much more rich and her accent is
much lovelier frankly so that's where we
developed her voice and there were these
letters between Shirley and Stanley that
I really that we got that Michael and I
read and those were probably the most
illuminating because it really showed
their sense of humor their intelligence
and also their love for each other
they had an unusual relationship that
was somewhat toxic in tons but but they
really did love each other and they
respected each other and they respect
each other's work and so those were
hugely influential feel like we're in
the Scottish play on average of madness
what will we started with with the
costume and the I had the padding and he
was wearing padding if there needs my my
costume to make me look a little bit
more like Shirley and that blended to a
certain physicality immediately and then
I felt like she had an uh an interesting
relationship with her body from what I
had read I thought it felt like she was
bit self-conscious about her body but at
the same time kind of not paying any
attention to it in a way on
self-conscious and self-conscious at the
same time and two things one I had
herniated discs in my neck about two
weeks before we started shooting and I
was an extreme pain for a lot of the
shooting of his movie and I honestly
think that let it it went to her
physicality in a good way because I feel
like she wasn't named basically a lot of
the time she did go up hills and I felt
like that actually really helped me
because I was so uncomfortable and and
my most comfortable position was sort of
this stiff position and I didn't want to
I could barely use my left arm my left
arm had lost a lot of strength so that
lent itself and then and then her her
lumbering thing her the way that she
like walked I don't know where that came
from I just it has no necessary it's not
necessarily accurate to Shirley Jackson
at all and III want to be respectful of
that it just kind of happened
and it just seemed natural it seemed
right and I so I just kind of went with
it
I don't it kind of I don't know where it
came from odd
it made me feel thrillingly horrible do
you know what it's like to have it it
was the first time I'd ever played a
historical figure or somebody that was
well-known like that and I think I'm so
glad that I was able to try the try it
for the first time with a little bit of
freedom and a little bit of
being able to take liberties because
it's definitely not quite as scary
at one point we did all our research and
all our work and we really tried our
best to learn everything we could about
them Shirley and Stanley and then at a
certain point Michael and I just agreed
that we had to kind of let it go and we
had to take everything we had learned
and kind of throw it away and try to try
to capture the essence of them and what
we loved about them but also do our own
interpretations of them for this
particular story so that we were
crippled by by the responsibility you
know I'm counting down from three three
two one
[Music]